happy 500th day of the trump presidency
oh yeah you guys feel it oh oh oh it
feels good you know it's true what they
say about time when you're having fun
it slows to an invigorating crawl Trump
has accomplished so much in his first
500 days or as Kellyanne likes to call
it the 500 days of American greatness
well usually presidents get measured on
their first 100 days but a great man
like Trump takes five times as long to
show just how great he is
I wish I could go over all of our
presidents incredible wins
things like teaching Boy Scouts about
yacht orgies or increasing Frederick
Douglass awareness making Jake Tapper's
a shithole so many good things but
there's simply not enough time so we're
setting up a Trump accomplishment ticker
to remind you of all the history Trump
has made in only 500 days but right now
we want to focus on Trump's latest
distinction and a letter leaked to the
New York Times this weekend we learned
that the president's legal team believes
that Trump can't obstruct justice
because he's president and it makes
sense
how can Trump obstruct justice when he
is justice that would be like Bruno Mars
obstructing charisma doesn't make sense
just take it from Trump's personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani
a man whose legal mind is so expansive
it's constantly pushing his eyeballs out
of his skull
yesterday Rudy went on TV to explain why
this whole witch hunt has treated Trump
very unfairly he believed he's telling
the truth he is telling the truth for
every one of these things he did we can
write out five reasons why you did it
if four of them are completely innocent
and one of them is your assumption that
it's a guilty motive which the president
would deny he can't possibly prosecute
yep
great point Rudy that's how you know
Trump is telling the truth because he
has poor versions of it he's he's the
Rashomon of alibis anyway not only
control not obstruct justice even if he
did the president can't be indicted as
Rudy told The Huffington Post that same
day President Trump couldn't even be
indicted for murder which is an
incredibly normal thing to say if you're
the lawyer of a man whose wife hadn't
been seen in 24 days moving on moving on
but bozer's even if Trump were indicted
he'd still be fine
because just this morning Trump
heroically tweeted that he has the
absolute right to pardon himself Trump
has elevated the office of the
presidency so high that it's currently
located above the law
so just to catch you up here's where
we're at Donald Trump is innocent
hashtag no collusion hashtag no
obstruction Donald Trump didn't do
anything but if he did do something
it is so not a crime but if it is a
crime he cannot be indicted and if he
were indicted he can pardon himself now
loser libs might call this moving the
goal posts but they couldn't be more
wrong Trump isn't moving the goalposts
that implies he only has one way to win
he's adding new goal posts dragging out
a soccer goal and a basketball hoop and
a skee-ball alley an Olympic halfpipe
and a Quidditch slave
good luck fighting the snitch Muller oh
you found three well guess what there's
eight now some of the mainstream are
skeptical that Trump has the power to
pardon himself the idea of Trump parting
himself I think is completely ridiculous
I have pretty severe doubts about
whether somebody could pardon themselves
no president in history has ever been
brazen enough actually to try it I got
news brazen enough to actually try it
with Trump's other campaign slogan to
weigh in on these complex legal issues
is citizen journalist Kobe labate
I'll ask you the question everyone's
dying to know can the president pardon
himself it's difficult Jordan some
people say it's physically impossible to
pardon yourself
they say the president doesn't have the
legal flexibility to bend forward wrap
his lips around his own pardon decree
and get himself off and to be fair no
president has tried you know you know a
guy at my high school claimed he could
pardon himself but everyone said he
would have to have a rib removed so that
it could do that rib things an urban
legend Jordan self pardoning it's really
just about finding the right angle
legally speaking and trust me self
pardoning feels amazing don't get me
wrong it's great when other people
pardon you but nothing beats closing the
door or looking down at your rock-hard
criminal record and pardoning yourself
dry interesting okay but alright but
answer me this what about all the
eggheads who say self pardoning is
unnatural or gross or a disgusting
perversion of the law did Jordan please
let's be honest most presidents have at
least thought about pardoning them I
mean who hasn't can you honestly say
that you Jordan Klepper when no one else
was home never once tried to pardon you
okay I tried once yes the only
difference is he's not ashamed to talk
about it and really there's nothing
gross about self pardoning I mean sure
giving a pardon it takes a lot of work
but you're also getting pardoned which
feels awesome I've outlined it here in
this legal diagram
here's President Trump the head of state
and here's his pardon power his raging
pardon represented by this sideways and
upside down letter P yeah of course and
here you see the the constitutional
spine which has more than enough legal
flexibility for the president to pardon
himself as you can see okay come on all
right so just just rub you the
Constitution definitely allows for this
you just have to kind of see you're not
worried to move like this could snap the
the country in half of course not sure
admittedly when the president pardons
himself there might be a big sticky
political mess to clean up afterwards
that's something the president has to be
prepared to swallow yes
very clear explanation with no subtext
whatsoever cobiella be everyone the
fight continues